à gauche kaïn claude journée au maillot
vert est une
la nuit d'essence au la steppe tout le
monde est couché tous les matchs à kef
repose écrasé bien heureux glabre et je
baille faisons comme eux éteignons la
lampe fumeuse qui grésille mais par dieu
petit lait qui vient là bas sont la
route
quel est ce bon moujik ivanovic mon fils
ma bouche la ta bouche la tienne il vont
battre chaque f ois le fils de ton père
ou à la mère de ma soeur je suis brisé
tour et que m'a complètement cloud qui
rien n'a changé ici
ainsi on a repas en lice pas chez la
table alors bonal ont pu me ciré ly est
toi qui lie du tous
tiens me tue un grand coup de pied un
grand coup de botte de total alors c'est
pas le moment
demain il fera jour alors bon dribble
canal tu es libre maintenant et quatre
ans de bagne impérial je me suis racheté
cher d'icade a et qu'on regarde
naturellement un tas pas changé toujours
si nerveux aussi exalté montre moi tes
mains ou juste injuste contre moi montre
moi tu incendie toujours à oui mais rien
des [ __ ] pétrole les flammes sont plus
généreuses ramener mon fils bien sûr mon
coeur tu brute perçue mais c'est l'enfer
tiens mon fils regarde pas la fête
qu'est ce que tu vois là bas il ya
quelque chose appuyé non tu reconnais
pas ton frère de benjamin l'idiot
tous profs oui le petit michel lentement
il s'en va à consciente au feuillet
michel strogoff c'est bien naturel si le
ruyet s'il avait battu va pas lui dire
qu'on joue aussi mais tu vas pas
l'embrasser chi et fort ils m'ont choqué
michelle wie c'est bon tu dis que tu
fais pour enfants que tu fais ton frère
tu es fait pas reconnu les petites
fautes coûtent pleure c'est fini c'est
tout est-ce que je pleure web
as tu devrais tous et nous on n'y pense
pas atc yvan tué terry n'est pas pour
chiens ouais mon petit papa moi même ce
soir avec la bonne venceslas avec la
bonne a je reconnais bien l'âge pour le
moins pas mon truc moi pas être heureux
de voir son fils du préfet yvan ne me
dit pas tout perdre neuf tu là
je l'embrassé la hausse des prix dans
mes bras judiciaire et quand thomas je
te laisserais 10-10-10 ferrer n'a pas
bien beau naturellement n'a jamais été
très expansif il ne m'est pas peut-être
mais si tu aimais à yvan écoute je
finirai par croire que tu n'es pas
sérieux pas à faire c'est grave
allez val jetée dans le jardin oui il
fait bien attention de pas de salies non
je ne faillirai pas bon montrer drôle de
revoir le service militaire ça change un
homme a passé 10 dont j'y pense il a
bonne là haut
rangez les traces des grosses bottes
j'ai écrasé un à la brebis
c'était une punaise mais on est là on
bat bat robin et jetez pas raconté la
derniers des spurs l'âme non ta fiancée
elle est là katia la gauche non sonia la
blondasse la diffuse
courroye non non ne m'ont pas n'est pas
vaccinée j'ai voulu l'embrasser part
j'ai embrassé le nez la bouche à bouche
je mets le nez la bouche tenu le nez la
bouche à bouche le nez le nez la bouche
évidemment la fal a manqué d'air mais
gonflé pour assoupir en gérait brûler un
cierge et me suis raspoutine vos chéris
connais bien la délicatesse comme tu es
bonne et douce
non je ne suis pas rancunière ou à la
toux c'est ce que tu vas faire
maintenant je n'ai non tu vas aller au
fond du jardin dans le cagibi me
chercher une casserole de poudre à canon
ont fait le crème du cidre jusqu'à
demain 6 dimanche six trophées la bombe
mais dis moi dans le noir j'y verrai
rien moi très juste musique
en revanche les allumettes regarder de
très près j sont toujours tête en l'air
c'est yvan toujours dans la lune elle il
se fait tard éteignons la lampe fumeuse
qui grésille demain n'est pas une
journée comme les autres à la ferme
demain on tu confonds